hey guys Pete here this will be part two
of my Westworld season 1 episode 3 recap
and review this video will be the
summary for episode 3 with analysis of
some of the storylines some questions
that came up and some popular theories
about the show some of the theory is
mine and I also look at some of the
other popular theories that have been
can you know been kicking around if you
haven't seen the first part of the recap
I'll put a link right up at the top here
if you click on that you can check out
that my scene-by-scene breakdown that I
put out yesterday as a warning this
video will contain spoilers for
everything that has happened in West
world up to this point with that out of
the way let's get right on it
so to summarize in episode 3 we got a
lot of new information about the park's
origin story and about how the hosts are
programmed to think some of what we
learned is pretty straightforward but
other events don't do much as far as
clearing up what's going on in the first
episode we saw the Loras killed a fly
which was an indication that she had
evolved to a different level than the
other hosts it wasn't completely clear
if she was lying to Stubb's and Bernard
when they were interviewing her but it
was a definite possibility in this
episode we find out for sure that
Bernard is using her as an experiment
but I also think that Ford is making
changes to her at the same time she
exhibits behavior that's outside of her
normal narrative she asked Teddy to
leave with her and that falls right into
the changes we saw Ford make with him
when he gave him his backstory we didn't
get a scene with Dolores and Ford but
there isn't strong evidence that Bernard
not rolling her back would lead her
right into Ford's new storyline either
so I'm left wondering if some of the
changes we see with her are normal from
an updated narrative and then others
like her improvising with Bernard at the
end are related specifically to what
he's doing with her he stresses that she
shouldn't tell anybody about what
they're talking about and we assume that
she doesn't do that on the other hand
though if he can tell her not to tell
anyone why wouldn't Ford be able to
override that decision we're gonna have
to wait and see what happens with her
before we know what either one of them
is actually up to the new storyline that
Florida's putting together seems pretty
badass we learned that he is pulling a
huge amount of resources and we learned
that poor Teddy never had a backstory
the one he god is kind of crazy and its
main character Wyatt
what for told us about Arnold's
bicameral mind idea teddy says that
Wyatt thought he could hear the voice of
God which is something that could happen
in the consciousness experiment to the
hosts if it made them crazy for did say
to Teddy that like all good fiction the
backstory has a bit of truth to it but
is that as far as it goes I mean that he
really just decided to use this on the
same day that they find out that this
guy exists or are they somehow related
whether or not that's the case why did
why it's men seem to be invincible I
don't think that's been answered at this
point and I don't think the reason
behind the straight taking off is all
that clear either if Ford just started
adding this to into the narrative what
he really had planned it in a way that
some hosts would just sneak off and join
Wyatt in the hills that it would
actually be the ones who have weapons
privileges specifically and what he have
made it so that they couldn't be killed
for some reason none of that really
makes sense yet and it doesn't seem
likely that anyone other than Ford knows
what he's planning Theresa did say that
he was using a lot of resources that
were causing problems for other
storylines but I would think she would
have been specific if the host had been
straying off I just assumed that he was
taking up a bunch of land that was
infringing on areas that other things
took place the existence of Arnall is
the big reveal of episode 3 in my
opinion but it is a reveal that asks
more questions than it actually answers
a couple of big questions are if weather
you know did he really die and why are
the hosts that are going off-script
talking to him if that's the case if
he's still alive how is he able to
influence things and does Ford already
know about it I mean Ford could be
launching this new narrative as a way to
get at him or is it just a matter of the
old code popping up to remind him of
that story the story is obviously
important I think you know based on what
other information we got about how hosts
make decisions it's odd that he bashes
his own brains it it's like he didn't
want to leave any evidence behind of
what was going on with him that kids you
know hint at self-interest that he
abandoned his loop to take off in his
own direction we know that he wasn't
programmed to have any interest in stars
but he was carving constellations into
his carvings hopefully in the next
episode we'll find out more
about what set him off on his path
because like I said he it's almost like
he was protecting a secret by bashing
his own head in that's not something
that he should have done after writing
these last few paragraphs down and then
thinking about it later I'm starting to
wonder about the changes we see in dr.
Ford in this episode to this point in
the story we've had the idea that all
he's really interested in is the
evolution of the host that he's created
there are quite a few examples of this
but what stands out in my mind the most
is when he was talking with Barnard
about evolution he says that people are
done since they've evolved to the point
of being able to keep even the sickest
amongst them alive this planted a seed
for me that he wasn't concerned about
the problems after the reveries because
at least things were moving along in
their development the whole speech about
mistakes being responsible for sentient
life led me to think that he has real
interest in the hosts evolution and
episode 3 however that he does a
complete 180 and is anxious at oh
bernard about how the hosts aren't more
than they seem every time he gets a
chance the host who went off the rails
after his update are starting to
remember things something he says they
shouldn't be able to do they're also
talking about arnold who known in
programming had ever heard of before and
he's someone who was essential in
developing the technology they work with
every day also at least oz Moore said
that Ford hadn't been involved in the
storylines for years and nothing about
him has shown he cares about the
corporate side of you know the park he
decided to step in and take over with
this idea so what was his motivation he
just had an urge to get back in the
saddle or does he think that his new
idea will be able to redefine the guest
experience I mean for how the park works
in its present state the ideally how it
seems like it would have been
entertaining enough but Ford gave a
speech saying that people come to the
park for a glimpse of who they could be
because they already know who they are
all this makes me think that everything
that's happening in West world might be
tied into this new storyline maybe some
things weren't exactly planned but I
think he started implementing the idea
before his big speech after Lee's
presentation we saw that he was spending
time out in the deserted area of the
park which means we know he's been
planning it for a while so that just
leaves the question of why is it so
special and when did he start to put
things into moe
could the idea of Arnold just be part of
the narrative could he be keeping the
staff in the dark for reasons that will
make his storyline more effective when
things start to happen
I think a strange change of behavior is
enough to consider it I mean the all
Arnold twist will be good either way but
let me know what you guys think do you
think he's a real person and the story
Ford tells Bernard is actually the real
story or do you think he was added as a
part of the new narrative if you don't
have an opinion you know which story
what which one are you gonna root for I
just think there's a little bit too much
in the way of you know similarities
between Arnold and then Wyatt for it to
be completely coincidence that both of
these characters came into the forefront
right at this time also let me know if
you think the host we saw in the
flashbacks is Dolores I've heard people
say Armistice as well so let me know if
you think that is a better candidate we
know Dolores is the oldest hostess in
the park and we you know we heard Stubbs
tell the tech that she's been repaired
so many times that she's practically
brand-new we also saw Peter Abernathy in
the flashback then he looked pretty much
the same other than his clothes but it's
interesting the wonder because they
showed that you know that host a couple
times it'll be interesting to see how
things develop with Dolores as it looks
like Bernard has set her on a path to
achieve consciousness
I guess the theorists will say that
Bernard is a host and is just acting
according to how he was programmed by
Ford
like I mentioned I'm not there yet but
let me know what you guys think about
that theory in the comments there were a
couple parts of this episode that made
Bernard seem like he may not be a human
another big theory that was going around
seems to be debunked by the events in
this episode there was one going around
that the man in black was actually
William whose story was taking place on
a different timeline basically that
Williams story was taking place thirty
years before the other stuff that's
going on but after seeing that what the
park looked like in the beginning it
doesn't really look like that's the case
they don't you know it didn't look the
same back then also even though Elsie
and Bernard don't show up in any scenes
with him
it seems like the you know what Dolores
showing up at the end hints that all of
what's going on is happening in the same
you know in the same timeline in the
present time that is to say that she ran
off into the night because of the
changes she's experiencing and it looks
like she ran into why
right after that the major thing I was
left wondering is what is the man in
black up to with Dolores when we saw
them take her to the barn in the first
episode the impression was that he was
going to force himself on her his
comment about wanting her to fight since
he paid so much money it was pretty good
evidence now that we've seen her
remember the scene new questions pop up
for context when he first came he
mentioned her still not remembering him
he then started dragging her off but had
to stop and kill Teddy along the way the
last thing we saw was him closing the
door in her memories we see that he says
let's start from the beginning and then
pulls out a knife if you think about it
he wouldn't need a knife to rape or
terrify her we saw him overpower her
easily in the yard and she's clearly
terrified already so was he planning on
scalping her this could make sense but
we see him take the dealer scalp with
him after he takes his and when they are
interviewing Dolores for the first time
she still has that blood on her cheek
that we see came from her father in the
very same scene if he isn't raping her
or scalping her what exactly does he do
with her in the barn and why is this the
memory out of thousands of times through
this narrative that she holds on to we
know she is the original host so it
makes sense that he would have a history
with her after visiting for 30 years but
it's hard to guess what he's actually
you know looking for from her either way
whatever he did to her was bad enough
that she was able to override her
programming to evolve into something
else when she remembered it even though
we don't see him take her scalp the maze
he found on the dealers might be related
if ro has something to do with the hosts
that are showing the strange behaviors
then hosts that have been around since
he was building them might be important
to the man in black we see him pick the
dealer out specifically to take him out
into the desert he then leaves the
minimum amount of blood he can survive
on inside of him and tells him that he
wants answers after that we see him
riding away with the scalp that has a
maze with a man in the center of it this
makes you wondered if Arnold is the man
in the middle of the maze or if he
designed the maze as a sort of test for
consciousness that is like if a host can
figure out what the maze is and can find
their way through it then that could
prove that they were
conscious being which could be what the
man in the middle of the maze represents
we've already seen we're gonna learn
more about the maze in the previews for
the next episode so we'll hold on I'm
making any crazy assumptions
it's another it was another good episode
even if we were left with a bunch of
questions
I think the pacing is good the look of
the world still gets to me and the
acting is super top-notch also the
effects in the eyeball scene were pretty
amazingly real I like the introduction
of Arnold to the story and I like the
interactions with Bernard and Dolores I
think that there's gonna be some
interesting stuff that's gonna come out
of that relationship based on the fact
that his son's death has such a big
effect on his life I'm excited to see
what Ford is planning with the new story
and hoping to get more info about what
the man in black and the maze are really
about since we didn't see much of him in
this actual episode let me know what you
guys think about it though and leave any
questions you have in the comments I
definitely consider doing a Q&A video in
between episode videos that people start
leaving more questions about things that
I didn't go over I mean this is like a
5,600 word document that I'm reading
right now and I know I left a bunch of
stuff out so just leave questions if you
have them and if there's a bunch I'll
make a Q&A video in between before the
next episode comes out please like the
video if you enjoyed it and make sure to
subscribe to my channel before you go
thanks for watching I will talk to you
soon